the voice is a huge hit and a new winner
will be crowned tonight with the hopes
of becoming its first breakout star
tell me that you've had three winners
now how have you seen it change their
life because some people say well they
haven't had a Kelly Clarkson yeah you
know most record companies that sign
artist for 20 years never get a Kelly
Clarkson a night in a bottle yeah I mean
the one in a million not just for a
reality show but just in the music
industry you have the struggling single
dad
versus the elementary music teacher
the college student I'll be the soldier
versus the TSA officer the big
opportunity for the voice contestant was
being able to for the first time last
night release original songs and new
music videos number one the people have
spoken team Adam is beyond proud / Matt
shooting to number one on the iTunes
chart you should have two winners tell
me how you see when on this show changed
these kids lives it long it throws you
into a you know catapults you into a
amazing place you get to be on these
carpets and talking people buy your
music and transcends just being on the
voice Adams other mentees Chris Jameson
and Damien also broke the top ten
Levine's got a 75 percent chance of
winning but watch out for team Blake's
Craig Wayne boy he's at number two with
the song meant for shelter he's awesome
and if he wins Adam sucks the winner on
tonight's finale on NBC will snag a
life-changing record deal I moved to
Nashville 11 years ago with everything
that I owned in the background Pavelec
it would seriously help a lot I mean you
know for me too for me to try to live
debt debt free and be able to help out
my family